comment vous dire ça
elle se bat et je me défends voilà donc
pour moi il ya eu une décision de
justice avec des juges qui connaissaient
le dossier qui vont sur la croix se
relaxer qui me relaxer oui je veux dire
que je suis innocent
et
derrière ça à photos postées qui crée
une émotion j'imagine bien que si si
j'avais la photo et elle est quand même
c'est vrai qu'elle est allée choquant un
way l'âge ou la voyage ou alors regarder
alain c'est vrai car on peut pas tout le
tout les tous les gens qui ont vu ses
fossettes photos sur les réseaux sociaux
tous les gens qui ont parlé de cette
affaire pouvait pas rester insensible
c'est vrai qu'à ce poste de de marcos et
faulquemont compte tout à fait on
comprends d'après des ja des personnes
que je peux comprendre et d'autres je
peux pas les comprendre en fait c'est ça
le le souci c'est que en tout cas dans
le judo je comprends pas les personnes
qui ont fait ça parce qu'ils me
connaissent très bien ils la connaissent
elles aussi turquie on fait quoi ma qui
ont
qui ont propagé après envoyé les
électeurs l'agresseur c'est ça parce que
enfin moi je le sens je me sens pas eu
les soeurs du tout alors dans une
conférence de presse margaux avait donné
sa version on va la regarder elle
revenait d'abord sur le début de la
sphère que vous seriez rentrée que selon
elle vous n'étiez pas dans votre état
normal vous avez donné votre version
assure à la regarde il était convenu en
tout cas quand je rentre je suis rentré
sur la route
qu'on se retrouverait chez moi du coup
avec alain
pour que j'emmène le lendemain lé report
pour cuire qu'il partait en israël il
arrivait beaucoup plus tard à 2 heures
du matin
[Musique]
alcoolisé je lui ai fait la remarque
aussi qu'il était tard que je l'avais
attendue quand même deux heures
je suis donc allé me coucher
hilmar il m'a rejoint
alors ce que dit margot là c'est vrai
vous êtes qu'alcoolisé vous étiez j'ai
fait un pot de départ j'ai bu quatre
bières
j'ai vu quatre bières et vous étiez dans
votre état normal pour vous j'étais dans
mon état normal oui enfin c'est assez
bien pour discuter pour commander mon
humeur pour
pour faire tout et n'importe quoi avait
aucun problème j'avais conscience de
tous je me souviens de tout je me
souviens des paroles
vous arrivez à la maison et là qu'est ce
qui se passe voilà ce qui se passe c'est
que déjà il me fait un bisou ensuite ben
comme elle disait je devais venir pour
imprimer des documents qui me permettait
d'entrer sur le territoire d'israël ce
qui ce qu'il faut donc c'est que il ya
une semaine tout allait bien entre vous
battouta les noms tous n'avaient pas
bien en fait si vous voulez c'est une
histoire qui est un cancer qui ont
investi ensemble tout bas on était
a été prévenue que je partais on savait
tous les deux ce que ça signifie donc
vous partiez en israël pourquoi je parte
en israël pour un job un job de la corde
au cou partie objectivement la barre
ouais je partais la barmaid hors contrat
d'accord d'accord mais j'étais super
content de partir et pour les papilles
au mans vous ai dit vous allez
l'amérique vous deviez pas partir en ce
moment c'était un billet j'ai pris qu'un
seul billet donc à votre histoire et
après c'est à dire que c'était la fin de
l'histoire entre margot et vous bah oui
enfin moi je ne ferme jamais totalement
époque parce que moi j'avais besoin de
prendre beaucoup de recul sur ma vie
dans mon travail je pense que j'ai
jamais fait à peu près le tour et je
voulais passer à autre chose donc vous
vouliez pu vivre cette aventure en font
donc vous rentrer le soir c'est votre
pot de départ comme vous dites puisque
vous partez le lendemain donc pour de
nombreuses semaines de nombreux mois des
années voilà exactement après vous
seriez peut-être revenu que vous pouvez
faire des allers retours mais voilà on y
serait donc vous passez cette soirée
avec vos potes pour venez à la maison il
est il et quelle heure il d
1h45 d'accord et la veille à votre
compagne donc margot qui est là ouais
bon bah
me dit elle et où tata cartouches
d'encre pour imprimer les fameux papiers
j'allais oublier d'en bas je suis à
rechercher l du coup elle l'apprend elle
ouvrait la prime de papier sur neuf
donc été un peu être un peu énervé on
dit ouais tu as attendu longtemps deux
heures je crois c'est ce qu'elle dit
elle dit alors qu'elle vous at on dit
d'eux aurait pu mal se jette dans son
lit est
d'accord voilà moi je commence à la
rejoindre finalement et bout de quelques
quelques secondes elle me dit enfin
c'est pas qu'elle me dise et qu elle
marmonne des choses et ça ça a toujours
été un signe avant coureur quand elle
commence à faire ça
c'est ça pue c'est à dire la pub ça veut
dire que là commence à
insulter commence à rentrer dans une
rage folle et vous disais quoi ben là je
dis rien en fait elles vous disent rien
l'accord ne comprenais rien que vous
entendiez marc monnet à côté de vous
dans le lit on va souffler marc monnet
et là du coup j'ai pris mes affaires qui
étaient à côté du lit je les ai prises
chalet dans le couloir j'ai fermé des
quatre noms la porte et là elle est
arrivée en courant de traitant de lâche
visite tu comprends rien elle et elle
est repartie dans le elle repartit dix
ans au en sautant dans le lit finalement
et puis là il restait quoi deux minutes
avant que c'est un bolt
oncle bolt arrive il restait deux
minutes et là
gibbons je te dis quand même au revoir
et tout et puis vous connaissez
l'histoire mais telle qu'elle est
destructrice je lui dis et puis que je
vais entraîner une israélienne qui
faisait rire l'abattra c'est ce que je
lui dis ça ça vous avez vous l'avait
piqué vous lui dites visite chez ses
parents en israël je suis entraîné une
israélienne qui j'espère te battre à
j'ai dit que j'y mettrai un point
d'honneur en tout cas moi et ça a
déclenché sa déclencher la suite c'est à
dire que tu allais je vais en créant
elma elle m'a chopé par le col du tee
shirt et puis je me dirigeais vers l'est
vers la sortie en reculant et puis là je
tape le montant de la porte a depuis
racheté un peu sonné et puis là c'est
parti et puis après je pouvais plus rien
contenir quoi en fait donc la question
est qu'est ce que vous faites est ce qu
elle fait mal à ce qu'elle fait c'est
que ça tire ça pousse ça crime est super
fort super super fort c'était c'était
une scène
je sais même pas la décrire en fait
parce que ça part vraiment dans tous les
sens on se cogne la tête dans chaque
dans chaque porte un radiateur on tombe
à genoux on se relève j'ai tombe dessus
on se relève on reprend les murs et ça
s'arrête pas j'ai l'impression que ces
interminables puis jusqu'à la fin au
final mans fini dans le dans le couloir
elle m'attrape la tête en le serrant et
me dit attends attends à la je fais tout
ça parce que je t'aime de trop
et là judicaire qu'elle n'a jamais aimé
qu'elle
il ya des mots que je peux pas dire
parce que elles sont deux des enfants
mais bon voilà j'ai dit ça et puis j'ai
voulu partir récupérer mon enveloppe est
là elle saute sur la sur la poignée de
porte et puis celle à 40 dans le couloir
en rampant dans le couloir extérieur je
parle en rampant où elle crie au secours
au secours au secours et là je n'ai
jamais revu là vous parti ou la laisser
là je vais vous aviez vu son état avant
de partir ou non non c'était pas rendu
compte non plus - moi non plus vous
aussi vous étiez blessé âgé j'ai connu
la tête mais je ne savais pas que
j'avais une bosse un coquard des
griffures shy pas d'être parti comme ça
je suis parti comme ça une première fois
il n'y avait pas de bruit je remonte et
toujours pas de bruit je suis descendu
il y avait la police est arrivée au même
moment en me disant est ce que c'est
vous je l'aimé lui c'est moi d'accord et
là la police vient il ce qui se passe
là pour lui cela il embarque
une mètres de la voiture a failli
menottes il mètres de la voiture je pars
une première fois au poste de police et
ensuite je vais voir un médecin je vois
un médecin et puis là
ben c'est tout en fait après meurent
menottes il m'emmène au poste de police
il a su parti pour 48 heures de garde à
vue
moi
c'est dingue parce que quand on entend
cette histoire on voit que c'est ici
c'est une histoire d'amour en fait un
tout simplement voilà qui est que margot
j'ai l'impression qu'elle est calé voilà
l'été et piqué que vous partiez
israël entraîné duty je pense que c'est
vraiment elle était était tellement
amoureuse voilà aussi que je ne sais pas
cette histoire nous attriste toussaint
quand on les écoute parce que c'est vrai
que l'on sent qu'on semble margot très
amoureuse et ça nous fait extrêmement
beaucoup de peine aussi pour elle vous
c'est vous l'avez vous l'avez ressenti
ça aussi capter ça par amour qu'elle
elle vous l'a dit
je suppose après vous savez
il ya eu plein de nuit où je me posais
la question est ce que c est ce que
c'est réellement de l'amour afin que je
ne sais pas trop ce que je voyais
exclusivement de la jalousie à chaque
fois là je vais voir là moi ce que je
ressens c'est une femme en détresse
jugeait franchement je sais pas comment
tu le centre aéré non mais moi je suis
c'est vraiment et pas assez parce que
lorsque je vous écoute j'ai envie de
vous croire et lorsque je l'écoutais
elle j'ai envie de la croire elle est
donc là nous on est un peu en tenaille
age 2 versions deux histoires racontées
par enfin la même histoire racontée par
deux personnes qui nous quitte ou les
tous les deux visiblement des des
blessures physiques etc moi la seule
question que je rêve opposé sait pour
quelles raisons pour ça le parquet a
fait appel puisque vous avez été dans un
premier temps relaxé mais malgré tout le
parquet fait appel donc moi c'est que
des suppositions parce que je sais pas
quoi vous dire déjà le parquet a le
droit de faire appel et
bon ils ont su et ils ont fait ce qu'ils
ont fait une première décision qui vous
a relaxé un l'a donc là pour revenir sur
l'histoire c'est trois femmes juges qui
ont pris cette décision oui je pense que
ma fille avait été entendue
quarante-huit heures donc c'est ça
pardon par la police et ensuite vous
êtes passés devant le dans le volant
suggère encore eu 20 heures où
j'attendais mon jugement et c'est passé
je pense que c'était la dernière affaire
à être jugé parce que j'ai eu le verdict
à vers minuit et demi il me semble et
alors elle a fait une interview dans une
interview à paris-match margot dit il
avait déjà cassé mon appartement envoyé
mon ordi en travers de ma cuisine fait
tomber la télé avant de quitter les
lieux
une autre fois il a mis ses mains autour
de mon cou puis l'a relâché et s'est
excusé il n'est jamais allé au delà de
ça c'est déjà beaucoup je n'avais pas
compris à l'époque avec le recul je
réalise certaines choses mais plus que
par les gestes si paris meaux qu'il se
montrait dur et je suis peut-être passé
un peu à côté aussi c'est vrai sa
part seulement
c'est à dire à chaque dispute que j'ai
eu avec margot elle a cassé
des choses dans son appartement à chaque
dispute donc c'est la tornade qui se met
en route et cassent des verts des
bougies
elle renverse des meubles elle m'a lancé
un tabouret au visage et un jour elle
recommence à faire ça et oui j'ai
renversé une armoire qu'elle avait voilà
avec son ordi et tout
voilà c'est maintenant une fois et jouer
je vous garantis que ça s'est arrêté à
ce qu'on n'avait jamais levé la main sur
margot jamais levé la main sur elle elle
est très difficile à contenir je la
maintiens je la maintiens elle a jamais
pris un coup elle n'a jamais pris un
coup de mou
et saha et c'est en commun tant que
détient son bain on était ensemble
[Musique]
disons que notre histoire a commencé en
2017 et ensuite après tout s'est
complexifiée parce que moi je suis un
homme marié à dakar et voilà est pas
d'accord est ensuite monté ensemble est
officiellement en fait
bah non parce qu'en plus moi si j'avais
dû être avec margot j'aurais fait les
choses quand même ensuite dans l'ordre
parce que moi j'ai failli au départ mais
ça a failli tout quitter pour marco
je me suis posé la question en fait
c'était tout le temps des disputes des
disputes des disputes et d'un côté je
comprenais pas ce que pour elle était
numéro 2 entre guillemets j'ai pas voilà
et
mai
j'étais toujours obligés de de la
contenir des ces deux-là de la raisonner
et puis ça c'était super c'était super
dur donc
sur le point de vue de la relation j'ai
aussi j'aime et or dans les dents les
agissements dans la façon de faire mais
je pensais pas qu'un jour il y aurait dû
y aurait de la violence
psychologique est tous
des menaces qu'elle m'a fait qu'elle m'a
suivi en voiture qu'elle est qu'elle
appelle ma femme sur le lieu du travail
qu'elles lancent des cailloux sur ma
fenêtre
qu'elle qu'elle me dise le qu'elle me
dise l'adresse de la nouvelle adresse ma
femme sans faire de phrase voilà j'ai
pour moi tout ça j'ai dit je te
comprends pas en fait je te comprends
pas je sais pas pourquoi tu me fais ça
voilà travail et époque on est à la base
de cette à la base non c'est elle qui a
mis au courant
et là votre femme là vous partez en
israël ce sens tout seul tout seul tous
à lui tout seul parce que je vous disais
c'est une histoire qu'on trouvait là
vous êtes célibataire maintenant fin
vous avez tous genres en instance de
divorce faut que les données de divorce
soit prononcé
voilà mais moi j'ai c'est ce que je lui
ai dit amour avant je dis non moi j'ai
besoin de prendre du recul sur tout j'ai
besoin de faire cette nouvelle aventure
et je vous garantis qu'à partir du
moment où j'ai dit que je que j'ai
accepté ce poste en israël à partir de
ce moment de relâche j'ai pu dormir
comme un bébé
j'étais super bien et j'ai même eu des
critiques à cause de ça juste parce que
j'étais bien ouais ce qu'il part et est
élu minutes et pétillant et ça y est tu
pars tu me laisses et tête et pétillant
alors mais après tu m'abandonnes après
après on peut la comprendre aussi
invoqué une femme amoureuse moi moi ça
c'est ça c'est ça c'est des phrases que
franchement et pétillant parce que tu
parles on peut comprendre qu'elle soit
que ce soit blessé parce que c'est vrai
qu'elle était la lévée l'air très
amoureuse de vous et vous voir partir et
vous voulez se dire il a envie de partir
et de me quitter mais je le sent heureux
de me les coulisses énorme axa l'ablette
s'écouter bien là non écoutez bien la
presse et où est dieu et elle me dit
elle dit aussi des gars je suis content
que tu dégages